hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of the witching hour
we are here on the interviews youtube
channel because haley and i have a very
special guest this time around it's
michael chaves the director of
the conjuring 3 the conjuring the devil
made me do it
hello it's so good to see you and
congratulations
thank you guys i am so excited to be
here
we're really excited to talk to you
about your movie but also
make sure our viewers know a little more
about you than they
might at this point so i kind of wanted
to start by going back to the very very
beginning
what is the the moment that you realized
you have to be
a filmmaker
you know i think just as a kid you know
i um
you know i i love making movies with my
friends you know i would make comics and
um you know it's so funny i
i was telling someone about this that
you know i
you know someone was asking me what was
my first horror movie that i saw and i
think it might have been one of the
nightmare on elm streets i think it was
like nightmare on street three or four
and i
saw it on vhs and you know that was
fascinating and honestly i connected
with
freddie so much more than i think a lot
of the you know the other um
you know 80s horror monsters and
i just thought that you know the idea
was fascinating and you know those
movies were so
just bizarre and bold and his
personality especially
as the series went on kind of you know
really you know got really wild
and you know it kind of also begins like
love of just like new line
movies and new line horror movies and i
was telling someone how they're
you know as a kid when i was drawing
comics i would put the new line logo
at the top of the uh the comics and um i
just
you know and so honestly i'm still like
to this day just thrilled i can't
believe i i have a movie a new line
movie that uh
you know i i get a uh with that logo in
front of it so
i mean i think it's yeah it started
there and just you know i think a love
of you know monster makeup
and you know just you know fake blood
and
um then i got into you know visual
effects as a kid and i was you know
doing a lot of like visual effects and
um you know that kind of evolved and you
know
i think that you know it's it's
interesting because i think that you
know the stuff i really love is a hybrid
of the two where you know
there's those practical effects um you
know we have a lot of
uh practical effects in the movie but
you know there's you know artful use of
cg and i think it's you know the hybrid
you know it's a
i don't think you know nowadays you can
totally abandon
um digital filmmaking or
you know cg elements even though i think
that they were always i think trying to
get away from
it in you know different respects but um
but yeah i think that yeah that's
probably a long-winded answer for
uh you know the beginning i mean maybe
it was long but now i do have a
follow-up just for fun
do you remember any i don't know like
like a story that you told when you were
making films with your friends when you
were
super young maybe something that still
sticks with you now
a story that when i was making films
i don't know i had a similar question
that might help um did you ever look
back on those movies you made with your
friends and realize oh we were trying to
do freddy
well you know we did do a lot of you
know whenever there was like a history
project or something or we had to you
know
you know do any report i would always
take the option of doing a video report
and you know always some kind of you
know reenaction or depiction of it
and they would always just end in these
kind of bloody scenes or
they'd always be you know it's like how
can i get makeup and blood
into the war of 1812. so
that's the topic for it yeah my first
one was uh dream warriors so i
completely
relate to your coming into horror that
was your first one
yeah that was the first real one like i
had seen kitty horror movies maybe but
that was
my parents were super strict and that
was at a sleepover and it snuck into my
viewing
it's funny that might have been mine
also i keep on you know
because that and also the fourth one
blend in together
um and definitely there's the waterbed
in the fourth one which i
have you know shamelessly pay homage to
um
in uh in the film but um but yeah i know
it
it's amazing you know it's funny because
i think that you know
i think there's so many people who are
hungry to see uh you know a reboot or a
remake or a continuation of that
series i think it's also so loaded i
think it's you know
and you know some people i think who
didn't grow up with it or don't
appreciate the magic there
you know it's almost stigmatized also
you know it's like they don't understand
what's so awesome about freddie
um and i think but you know i see the
inspiration of it in like
christopher nolan films you look at
inception and you know slipping into
dreams and
rooms that rotate on themselves i mean
it
was all done in you know nightmare on
elm street
i like this idea of uh six degrees of
kevin bacon but playing the game with
nightmare and elm street
yeah exactly so what would you say
is the moment that all of it felt real
because it's one thing to say you know i
want to grow up and i want to be a
filmmaker it's another to have that
moment where
the dream feels attainable so is there
any specific thing that kind of
launched you to that next tier
you know it never
it's a combination of i was always
preposterously saying like i'm the
director from like you know i was
15 i'm like i'm gonna be a director you
know i'm a director
um and so in one way i was you know just
brazenly uh claiming it you know even
when i wasn't getting paid for it or
anything
at the same time i still to this day
don't feel like it's real you know it's
like even on these days where you kind
of go on to the lot
and you know i get that thrill like um
i think everyone else does where it just
feels surreal going on there and you
know this is the place
that i mean you're i'm like working on
the warner brothers a lot i have an
office on the warner brothers lot and it
just feels surreal
um so so yeah and also i think it's a
gradual thing i think that it's you know
the my quick biography is you know i
or at least immediate short-term
biography is you know i did
you know the maiden which is the short
film and um
that got a little attention thankfully
got the the right attention from the
right people
james saw it and he loved it new line
saw it and they loved it and they they
had been developing this
you know this la girona movie um so they
brought
they brought me in on that and i think
it was you know i i honestly owe a huge
debt to
david sandberg not he didn't hire me but
he i think that
he's because he's so awesome and he did
so well with lights out and
newline was kind of you know doubling
down on this idea that hey you know guys
who do shorts
you know we can we can shape them we can
you know get them to do movies so
i definitely benefited from that you
know we did la yorona and
honestly i just got along great with the
new line guys and we struck up a
friendship
um and then you know also i've really
connected with james i think that you
know james is really i mean it's like
oh first of all he's a total hero of
mine i'm totally coming at like
conjuring and
you know the whole universe is you know
a big fan um
but uh i i think that he's also just
he's just an awesome guy he's very
relatable and very down to earth and
i think that that kind of you know all
those things just lined up
so you know when he was looking to hand
over the reins
he was like he called me so
um but i think the thing that no one you
know that i don't talk about it's like i
was directing commercials before this
and i was like slogging away and
you know a lot of times like some of the
commercials were cool
um you know i did a couple music videos
i did a billy eilish uh video but
it's so good oh thanks thanks
so incredible um but you know a lot of
them
weren't cool and they were just i was
just paying the bills it was just like
really hard and so in
in terms of like when did it feel real
it's funny in terms of how it never
feels real it's like
you're you're like i'm slogging away at
like on like a mcdonald's commercial no
no harm to mcdonald's i love mcdonald's
but like
um you're kind of like i'm like is this
the dream am i am i living the dream i
mean technically i'm directing but
this doesn't quite satisfy like you know
you're deep
i don't know i think you're always kind
of going for it and it's interesting
because you know when i talk to other
guys
i think that that feeling of you know
you're always kind of trying to get at
whatever that ephemeral thing is
you know you know i don't know if it
ever feels real
you so there are a lot of horror shorts
out there it's a very popular category
for shorts and
obviously quality is a major factor but
i'm curious when the maiden really got
out there and got this response and when
you started talking with james wan
what were the elements of yours
specifically that really resonated what
was the feedback you kept getting back
you know i think that they they like
that i just put the focus on scares
i think that um you know i think they
also liked
the personality in it i think that there
is kind of a you know a dark comedy in
it and it's not
it's not comedic but i think that there
is you know that the idea of a real
estate agent who
wants to sell haunted house i think that
there was something about that that was
you know i still love that idea i think
there's something fun and sticky about
it
um and i think that they just they
you know that kind of lined up with a
lot of sensibilities within new line i
think they they just
you know they like that but you know i i
think without a doubt i mean i would you
know
i would be wrong if i didn't say it i
mean just there is a huge degree of luck
you know there are so because i see
those so many of these you know
awesome horror shorts out there and i'm
like
there are there's so much talent out
there and i'm sure there's so many guys
out there who are like
i'm so goddamn talented why am i not
directing you know why am i
why do i not have this movie um and so
i think that that there was a huge
degree of that
going back to the the commercial
experience so i know that might not be
you know maybe the most creatively
fulfilling type of
content to make but is there anything
about making those commercials and being
you know confined creatively in that
sense that has
bolstered those creative skills when you
got the chance to actually use them in
film
yeah i think you know you're i think
you're always learning and i think every
experience you know
you know it does pay off in unexpected
ways
the um you know the uh
you know it's funny like back to the
mcdonald's commercial i didn't do a lot
of mcdonald's i've only done a handful
but like
you know one of the things that um you
know that
you the great thing about commercials
the kind of the big headline is that
you're you get a chance to work with a
bunch of different people with a bunch
of different
you know each commercial has a different
problem that you're trying to solve
and you also get to use a bunch of
different tools and you know
as simple as um the uh
you know there's this thing called the
periscope lens and it's used you know a
lot for food and it looks just like a
periscope but you can like
you know get in very close focus and you
know get these kind of
you know impossible angles and you know
you know where am i going to be shooting
food in a movie it didn't pay off there
but the other
thing that you know uh you know i
learned when i was
using that shooting big macs is um that
it can go underwater you can actually
submerge it and that ended up being in
the uh the bathtub scene where
you know we were kind of debating about
do we just build a whole bathtub and
then have like a piece of plexiglas to
kind of get in close
you know on our girl as she's drowning
and
i was like well we could just use the
periscope lines and it was something
that you can just kind of like get right
in
in there and it's you know one of those
things that
because you know it's not always you
know those solutions aren't always
offered and you know sometimes hopefully
you're working with the right guys who
you know suggest that but
you know sometimes it's just like your
own experience and i think it's those
type of things where
you you get to work with you know a
variety of different tools and then i
think also it's just
being able to synthesize ideas and work
with different people you know
whether it's like you're working with a
you know an advertising agency or a
client
and you know understanding that
everybody has needs and you know the big
thing with
when you're making a movie especially
studio movies there's so many
you know there's so many voices there's
so many
ideas a very valid ideas that you can't
just dismiss
you you can't be well i guess you could
you know there's lots of guys who do
that and just you know they make their
own movie
um but i think that you know sometimes
it's to their detriment and sometimes
they're missing
what could be really good ideas or
they're missing guidance that
you know that i think that you know i've
learned honestly so much from
the the guys at new line you know that
is a great you know without object
without a doubt everyone always asks
like what what did james teach you like
what's the secrets james
james taught you and of course without a
doubt james has taught me so much
my you know working relationship and
friendship
with him has been amazing and i am a
better person for it
what no one ever talks about is like
what did new line teach you it's like it
is that
that place is filled with with creative
executives who
you know they grew up loving movies
loving new line movies
they're now working there and they've
got they've worked on so many movies and
they have so much experience and
honestly like they
you know there's so much great stuff
there so i don't know back to like you
know the commercial
you know the learnings from commercials
i think that part of it is just
you know being able to synthesize good
ideas and navigate it because you know
sometimes you'll get two
conflicting awesome ideas you know and
what road do you take
i also wanted to jump back to bury a
friend for a minute because i am
a big fan of billy eilish who isn't uh
everyone i know loves that music video i
did not realize he directed that until
very recently
while researching for this podcast but
and as much as like i've
spent my life learning about and being
passionate about filmmaking i don't
really know
anything about making music videos so
i'm
guess i'm curious that felt like such a
definitive moment in her career a
definitive video just that sort of phase
of her aesthetic
what is it like combining your
directorial vision with like an
upcoming pop star's whole vibe
and you also have to satisfy the song
and tell a story within your video
it made me realize i know nothing about
this form
yeah i mean i think that you know coming
down to luck
i was extraordinarily lucky to
to work with her on that that film
music video i don't even know what i'm
talking about anymore we've been doing a
lot of press
um it super lucky she's amazing
she's you know she came at that with
you know basically a full deck of the
visuals like she was like
this is you know i want this almost like
a
abduction probing you know sequence and
i want to you know basically i want to
be
levitating i want to spin and then she
pulled up a reference of you know
like how she's going to spin and you
know some of it you know
you know a lot of what i delivered was
more kind of like little
nuanced things it's you know finding the
right location and finding something
that feels
like the right vibe i think that you
know without a
without a doubt she's she's really
talented and she's a genius there's a
reason she is
as successful as she is at such a young
age
and you know i have no doubt that with
every i mean
she's directing her own videos and i
think with every video she comes at it
with a very
fully formed vision i mean the the
touches that i did were
you know and sometimes that's all it
takes is just these kind of the small
little like details like you know the
in that that kind of white void where
these hands are attack you know
attacking her and you know working her
and stabbing her with syringes that was
something that um
you know with that i just brought up the
idea of this kind of interactive
lighting the idea that we would
um you know it would kind of come on and
off in this kind of a very
you know bold way so you like within
within different freeze frames it would
almost look like we're jump cutting and
i just thought that that could look
really cool where you could like play
out a scene but then you're
you're getting different you know looks
of her and it's funny because you know
that was uh i just shamely repeated
myself in uh the conjuring at the very
end of the film there is kind of a
couple moments
with a character where i literally
literally did that and it was funny
because my editor
was looking at the footage and he said
it's a jump cut it's a jump
it's there's a jump cut in the footage
like he couldn't explain it and really
it was just this you know this kind of
strobing
you know uh uh sequence that we had with
the light that um
you know that that kind of gave that
effect is that so there's no movie magic
behind that effect like something
something beyond the strobe to actually
make that work
no it was all the you know all that i
mean honestly that's one of the things
that
you know i've always been really
fascinated i know it sounds like so
cheese ball but like i'm fascinated by
light and i love like moving light and
interaction
of light and um you know even you know i
think back like one of the first times i
was noticing it was like in the
american version of the ring where you
know there was the lighthouse i just
thought that is such a cool effect
and just like you know it was something
that i wanted to play with a lot in this
movie is you know not just
you know using like in a targeted way
and kind of using it to kind of
you know accent moments and you know not
just it doesn't need to be
like the jump scare doesn't need to like
reveal the the demon or something but it
can actually like you can kind of bring
it in like
there's the scene in the motel where
lorraine is is you know
remembering something that happened
earlier in the movie and
you know there was a lot of it might
have even been written whereas a
flashback
to to what happened so we were tying it
in
and i just thought you know we we had
seen it basically an hour ago there's no
reason to actually do a flashback to it
but you could
we could almost evoke that feeling of
of a memory by just having like light
passing by like cars like in the parking
lot and there was something about that i
was like
i like the way it came out i thought it
looked cool i don't know if anyone's
like
distracted like why is there so many
lights going on through the hotel room
i feel like i'm jumping way ahead but
now that you've brought up lighting i
just have to ask what it was like
constructing that one shot out in the
woods
the one that's featured in the trailer
where the light changes drastically
all around lorraine how how exactly do
you
accomplish that is that all done in
camera yeah that's all in camera
it um basically it was on we put a big
light we shot it at night
so you know the shot is we're looking
down at lorraine in the woods
and it looks like we're in the day and
she she goes in she kneels down goes
into revision
and as the camera drops down the light
dramatically changes and
looks like the sun sets almost like a
time lapse effect
and um the way we did it is we just shot
it at night and we lit it for the day so
we had a big light
it was on a techno crane and that techno
crane was on
this really really long piece of track
and so we just retracted the crane
retracted the light we're moving the
light through the forest and then like
moving it along the crane
and um and it was great yeah there was
no
visual effects in it so much so that if
you look
very closely and i think even in the
trailer
um you can see we have like
uh her mark is under her foot it just
peeks out just a little bit
but it was like it was one of those
things that we saw really late in the
game
and it was there was debate about you
know do we just get visual effects to
clean it up it's very easy it's done all
the time
but i was like no i want to be able to
say that there was literally no visual
effects in that shot
and so i left it in as proof
i very much respect that choice
committed don't tell anyone this podcast
isn't going out to anyone is it
you know the first thing i'm going to do
when we hang up is i'm going to go look
in the trailer and look for the mark
yeah i feel like i wanted to ask a
couple other questions and now i can't
remember them like before getting in oh
i just wanted to ask you did you get any
free mcdonald's
that feels like an important one to ask
you know what you actually get
if you're working on a mcdonald's
commercial and you're working at the
mcdonald's shop
is like the you know they have these
stores that well there's you know one
store in
chicago and then one store in la that
it's just dedicated to shooting
basically you get i think it's like
three o'clock fries where they go
and usually like the oil has been kind
of worked over like for a day
this is like the freshest oil it's the
cleanest oil you'll ever get
and they bring they cook these fries and
it is literally the best fries you'll
ever have because of course mcdonald's
fries are amazing but it's like imagine
like the very best version of it
at three o'clock like right at the end
of it it's like literally you want that
on every shoe day
that sounds incredible habit to get into
that also gave me the chance to think
about my more serious follow-up question
from before
because you know we're always reporting
on this
end of you know there are so many cooks
in the kitchen
and like the executives are making the
directors do this
you have such a good relationship it
seems with the folks at new line so what
would you say
is one of the most important things to
have between a director and executive
relationship in order to have
a successful collaboration it's a good
question i mean i think
you gotta have the right executive i
mean i think that's like what it comes
down to i think that you know the guys
at new line make it very easy
you know they're very easy to talk to
they're very collaborative
and you know they they support your
ideas you know they
you know they don't try and jam
in you know they'll they'll pitch their
ideas but they're also very just
democratic they you know
and sometimes like when it comes into
editorial um
you know they might have notes and you
know it's we'll try those notes in the
edit and then we'll
we'll test it in with an audience and
yeah i've seen it go both ways sometimes
it's a note where i'm like
i don't know if that's going to work and
it works and without a doubt you're
going to use that
they never say like told you so it's
it's always just like this kind of like
let's
test it let's see if this idea works and
you know i think that those environments
i mean that's the way it should be it
should be
best ideal wins it should be you know
you there should be a safe place so you
could you know develop and work on
things i mean there's this
you know everybody loves pixar there's
this great um
book on pixar uh i think ed catmull
wrote it called creativity
creativity incorporated do you guys read
that
i should read that i'm obsessed with
pixar read it
it is the absolute best you know for
you know pixar fans filmmaking fans fans
of creative management as crazy as that
sounds like
and it's it's got the most in the i mean
first of all so it's just awesome
because it's behind the scenes on pixar
but part of it just talks about their
process and just how
you know you know what what does it look
like and how they you know they have
this this great saying called uh fail
and fail fast where it's just like
you they just make the movie as quickly
as possible they get the movie on its
feet as quickly as possible
and they see what works and what doesn't
and they they admit in the book and i've
heard this in other other interviews
that
their first movie their first cut of
their movies are always god-awful
they're always terrible
but but they can build off of that and i
think that you know the idea of an
iterative
iterative process in making a film
it's i think it's a new idea that's kind
of come across like
thanks to pixar and thanks to animation
over the course you know these past
years but i think that
you know marvel has that i think that
the idea of you know
we're gonna shoot it we're gonna test it
we're going to feel it out and we're
going to course correct i think that
that's
i think that's a really interesting way
of making a movie
i think it's an interesting thing too
because uh similar to what perry was
saying about executive
like the idea of executive overreach i
think a lot of people have a negative
connotation
about test screenings but a lot of the
filmmakers we talk to have a really
positive relationship to them and find
them very helpful
yeah no 100 i mean honestly
i would absolutely
second that triple that i you know i
think you know i think the guys at new
line said you know that
they haven't worked with anyone who
likes testing as much as i do
and it's such an awesome experience you
basically get to bring in an audience
you got to put on a show you got to show
them you're moving
at whatever stage it is and sometimes
it's just not good
but i mean the truth is my movies are
always good even in the rough estate
but you get to just put it on its feet
and then you get to see what's working
and
it is it is so clarifying
for a filmmaker i think for a creative
person because
i mean it's it's easy in anything that's
creative to get
sidelined on something that's irrelevant
you know there's sometimes i'll look at
a shot and i'll be like
this composition is terrible i
screwed up this the scene doesn't work
the composition doesn't work and then
you start like cutting around that shot
and it's it's like it's not about that i
mean it's about the story it's about
these bigger things and sometimes you
kind of you just
need and you need to feel it with an
audience to
to to realize those things i mean and
ultimately
you know i mean it's the same thing with
with theater i mean theater you know it
you know they
they test there i mean it goes on the
road i mean they're they're you know
there's so many different
i think that the idea that a movie
always is you know comes out fully
realized and i think you know some
people can do it i think a guy like
fincher and a guy like
nolan can you know deliver you know a
movie fully conceived and they don't
need to test it
um but i think that there is
you know you go back to like charles
dickens would like change his story he
would like basically release a lot of
his stories episodically in these like
little
you know little chapters and he would
respond to
to audience responses i mean basically
as people were reading it and
commenting on it they you know he would
make adjustments which you know
that sounds you know almost so far ahead
of the times i mean now you see tv
storylines kind of you know being
adjusted based on fan response but
i think that there is something about
that where you know we're making this
for people for like a theatrical
experience for a shared experience for
people to
enjoy it and you if that's the goal of
course you want to hear what people are
thinking as soon
as possible i don't know if we should
save this for spoilers but for
the conjuring three in particular what
was the biggest takeaway from
those test screenings the biggest
takeaway
is that it was the scariest most awesome
movie that's ever been made
ah i think that from um
no notes actually not none yeah new
notes
from the very first one that was a rough
cut and we just screened it again and
again and we kept on getting that same
response
no in all seriousness because i have to
shamelessly plug the movie
people love it it has gotten a great
response and it has from
the very beginning i think a lot of that
honestly is due
to the world that james set up and the
characters of the warrens i think
you know especially after this crazy
year that we've had everybody just
wants to come back and
you know have some comfort food i mean
you know and you know coming back to the
warrens and that experience you know
you know i think our relation the
relationship the lawrence have with each
other and then our relationship to them
i think that there is something that
um you know is kind of nourishing about
that in terms of the testing
the uh the biggest thing that we changed
was there was a demon
that was not working um and it was very
similar to
the situation in um conjuring two you
know there was
i don't know how much you guys know
about it but there was um valik
the nun was not the nun the nun was a
creation in additional photography
um you guys know the story i don't know
the clown tell me i said i don't and i
feel like a clown tell me more
it's funny it is out there and i think
even james released some
concept art of what the i've actually
never seen what the
true was photograph demon looks like in
the
original one um but it was something
that i think
you know in in you know to his credit
new line's credit the movie tested great
it was you know everyone loved it and it
was just something that james just felt
like he could do
like there was something else there and
you know he started thinking about this
evil nun and he uh that's that was the
birth of the nun and it was all through
additional photography
um and with this we had
you know this is a very different
conjuring movie it's you know we're
taking a big swing
and that was the the idea with it is
that it would be a departure it would be
it's not going to be the typical haunted
house movie that that has been
done and really incredibly well explored
by
the you know the previous two movies but
also all the spin-offs you know that's
the
you know definitely been been their
format so
you know we james and the studio wanted
to get back to the roots of
paranormal investigators you know it's
like and that was something that always
appealed to me you know when i
you know when i first saw the first saw
the conjuring
and so this is more detective story and
it was more a story that was going to be
complicated
and needed you know some some mystery
and needed to go on the road
and needed some kind of clarity in the
resolution um
i think that if you look at the other
movies sometimes the connections between
the demons and why the how the demons
exist um
you know there is it's loose but you buy
it because it's
within the confines of a haunted house
you buy it you know
you know why does the crooked man exist
with the none
exist with the old man what are these
different they're different forms of one
you know and it kind of is singular and
it
you know it takes the shape of you know
this one haunted house experience
i think once you start going out into
the world and you have you're creating
more of a mystery
it those old rules of we can
have a variety of different demons and
creatures
starts to uh starts to get tested
and when we were testing it i think
that's really what we found out is that
you want the movie to kind of come
to a resolution and come to a focus and
you know come with an easy explanation
that
makes sense and you know we the
demon that we had was
was awesome and interesting and true to
life true to the accounts both of
david glatzel and and arnie they both
described this
this creature that was haunting them um
but it just didn't fit in the movie it
was just too
too complicated just because i'm curious
now
like if we want to picture something
would it
would it look anything along the lines
of the face that appears in the waterbed
yes yes but there's more to it yeah
it's basically the most terrifying thing
you've ever seen oh okay we
had to cut it we had to look through it
now it was too scary
it's too scary it was just i mean that's
of course that's a lot of the criticism
when people say it is is this movie too
scary should it even be released in
theaters
is it responsible you know i don't know
some of my favorite kinds of
conversations
as you mentioned this is though like a
very different type of conjuring
film and you mentioned you guys
ultimately
cut out what people might expect in the
demon front they are out in the world
it's not the traditional haunted house
so i'm curious like outside of obviously
the love story between the warrens was
there anything that you found
did have to you had to retain
i have to retain from this true story or
what was the from the
the sort of hallmarks of the franchise
so far
yeah you know honestly that was
something that was
was tricky to navigate because you know
once you get
if you look at a lot of the the scares
and conjuring movies you know there's
you have kind of shadowy creaky doors
you have toys
that come you know spring to life or you
know are behaving strangely
there you have a lot of these kind of
family home
devices and um
you know as we were developing it you
know without a doubt i was shamelessly
trying to get random uh
speaking spell toys out in the forest no
i wasn't doing that
but like you know you try and think like
well what is you know we're in the
forest the warrants have never been
in the forest you know what is the you
know what is the experience that's going
to be in there and i think that
you know with that some of it just
you know the movie needed to take its
own leap forward and become
its own thing i think that you know as
she connects to the
you know the events that happened in the
forest that you know it's a murder
sequence
um i think that you know that was you
know even though we've seen
things like it in the first in the
second conjuring you know it
it became its own thing you know and
alternating between these kind of two
realities i think that there was
you know something really fun about that
and you know i think that
the movie said
defined the what it wanted to be you
know i think that part of it was just
you know trying to i mean
as i've said before you know i'm coming
at this as a fan you know and i think
that you know i want to make
i want to keep that because a lot of
people say you know like
what was your spin like how did you want
to take this in a bold new direction i
was like
i actually would have been happy doing a
classic haunted house movie
um i think that the you know this
the the idea of kind of making it more
into an investigation came
from james himself and ultimately i'm so
grateful for that
i think that pushing it in a new
direction and
putting it in putting the warrants into
places and situations we haven't seen
before
it it be cut
it gets to be its own thing and it gets
to
to show that a conjuring movie can be
many things i
you know as you guys know i'm totally a
fan of collider and totally a fan of you
guys and it's funny because perry i
remember you talking about when you
first saw
this first conjuring and it was when you
were you said it was uh
it was called the warren files and the
idea that it would be spun off into you
you would have
case files that would take different
shapes and
you know i i heard that because that's
exactly what i
thought when i first saw it and it
reminded me of like the x-files and in a
way i saw these guys it's like okay the
warrens are like
this like folksy christian x-files like
mulder and
scully you know and i i kind of was
waiting for that movie i was waiting for
the promise of that to be delivered
and i think because the first film is
it's so awesome and you know that
haunted house experience
it's like you want that itch over and
over again i think that that's why we've
seen so many of these haunted house
movies
but i think that that's not the be all
end-all of what a conjuring movie can be
and i think that that's where
that's what i'm most that's what i was
most excited about ultimately about this
movie and also where
the franchise is headed you know it's
it's not gonna
be it is gonna
it's gonna kick the tires on your
expectations
i cannot wait to see more i'm just like
as you were explaining that i was i was
trying to convince myself well like no
some of the other installments have
broken out of the haunted house mold but
but no i'm now that i'm thinking about
it you could call the nun a haunted
house movie all the annabelle movies are
set in a house which is very much
you know actively haunted in a
traditional sense but with a creative
spin depending on who the director is so
i i'm kind of like first clicking into
place if this is the first time i've
seen a conjuring movie get out into the
real world in that sense
it's like the matrix basically right
yeah a little bit a little bit
um i did want to ask about working
with vera farmiga and patrick wilson
i imagine they are lovely people but
they
are acting veterans who have now played
these characters and i guess this is the
fourth film
so when i try to imagine myself in your
shoes
i can't even begin to imagine myself
giving them direction on these roles
that they know and play
so well so how does that factor in to
your work with them as an actor's
director
they're awesome i mean without a doubt
and you think you know the
the image that you see that they project
is absolutely true to form i mean they
are they're just
awesome two awesome people they're
really they're great at their craft
they're great actors
um they also have just this incredible
friendship
together you know they i think that it
translates to just a great chemistry on
screen you know
people talk about you know essentially
the love story of the convert movies
that that threat of a love story and
that powerful love story is you know
really one of those things that just
keeps
keeps us coming back um and it's because
i think that they have so much you know
honest just like
friendship and respect for each other
their their families are really good
friends they hang out together they
you know i i i think it's you know it's
really real and
rooted in a genuine place um you know
without a doubt i was coming in i mean
with the whole thing i mean i was like
i was like i just want to make the best
contrary movie possible and like how
what how are they going to be you know
what's what's it going to be like i mean
because they're
powerhouse actors they're really
established and awesome
and they were great i mean the bottom
line is you know they
were so collaborative and receptive
and you know they you know in the very i
think that
where my fears were first totally
realized was in the very beginning and
with it was just in understanding how
they work
so differently and with vera
she's you know very intuitive she's very
she comes to set
she knows what she wants to do or she's
just emotionally
ready to go she's you know she doesn't
even you know if it's up to her she
doesn't even want to rehearse she's
really just rehearsing
for the benefit of the other actors um
but she's
she's ready to go and it's almost like
she is lorraine warren she's like
in this kind of emotional intuitive way
she's like i'm there
i'm tapped in i'm like ready to go and
so you know i
bear on one side and then with you know
with patrick i'm like laying out the
scene and you know vera's like chomping
at it she's ready to go
and then patrick i get done explaining
you know basically how it's all gonna go
and what i'm thinking
patrick is like
okay so we're starting over here
and you want okay and you want me to go
over here and he's like asking these
questions and i'm like
oh my god why is patrick wilson asking
so many questions did i do something
wrong
is this wrong and he kind of keeps on
going he's like so i start
here and i walk over here and this is
where you want me to say that line
and i'm like yes
he kind of goes through it and he's kind
of like thinking he's like but wait wait
a second would ed
okay let me but he like goes through it
and what i realized like after kind of
like
going through the process for the first
couple days is like he's just talking it
out
he's just like and in a way he's like
kicking the tires on
the scene like he he really wants to
verbalize it and
experience it and you know almost like a
pilot kind of goes through the checklist
of like i got this i got this like i'm
ready to take off like he kind of wants
to kind of go through everything and
it's funny because then
vera's waiting there patiently like
obviously this is not her first time
working with patrick
and he's just kind of like really
talking it out and where at first i was
like oh my god this is exactly what i
was worried about he's not gonna listen
to my direction he's like it's not gonna
you know it's like
i'm gonna be totally wrong but then it
was like oh no this is awesome
like first of all brookie condren
working with patrick and vera
but like you know it's like it's his
process and
that actually was so informative to me i
mean of course
every every creative person comes out
things differently everyone works
differently
but it was actually like i learned a lot
from that just in terms of
it's good to kind of almost just like
verbalize
what you're doing you know sometimes you
kind of get into a situation and i think
he's probably
he probably has developed that
after not asking those questions after
going into scenes and like finding
himself in a situation where he was like
wait a second hold on now i'm on the
other side of the room and i'm
supposed to get to to their with what is
you know and i think that
like that was really informative and
honestly like i learned you know just in
terms of
i mean how awesome that was but they
they're always down to go with it
they're you know and they're just like i
was saying with the new
with you know the guys at new line you
know they want to take your ideas
and make it awesome they want to get the
best version of it you know they're not
there to
to challenge it i mean they're the best
like team players possible
um so yeah
i like hearing that about them doesn't
surprise me
haley should we should we put the the
spoiler warning on i feel like
we we might need this time for that all
right this is it guys if you have not
seen
the conjuring the devil made me do it
know that it's in theaters and available
on hbo max
on june 4th go check it out and then
you'll be able to watch the rest of this
video
press pause go watch it and then when
you reopen this window it begins right
here it's that easy
all right spoiler warning goodbye to
everybody who hasn't seen the film
oh my where to start do you have it do
you have any burning questions hayley
before i jump in
my burning questions you haven't even
asked me do you want to throw in a
burning question you can
um i do i have a
like a broad when okay so this is a big
franchise that has
much room to go and with something like
psychic powers there's so many freedoms
in the way that you could take that
and so i'm curious how you decide how
far
lorraine's psychic powers go
if there's any concern about interfering
with the future of the franchise if
there are guidelines
how how powerful is she and how do you
decide
you know it's honestly a conversation
with everybody you know it's i think
that
um you know james and newline are the
stewards
of this franchise and you know they're
going to be um
you know uh you know navigating this
through
spin-offs and you know other other
movies i think that you know with that
it's a great question and with psychic
powers you could probably solve any
mystery very quickly
um so you know there needs to be some
kind of limits uh you know put on her
it was um you know there was just
there was a lot of different um
moments i think one of the things that
actually comes to mind that you know
became kind of a deal breaker
is um is with
this is a spoiler guys don't
you see go see the movie why are you
watching spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie i guess it's my big question
um because it just ruins it there's
you learn nothing from the spoilers um
when with um
you know there was i i we were playing
with an idea you know all
you know from the very first draft there
was the idea that um
he doesn't you know just as a joke he
doesn't shake hands because the chicken
[ __ ] he has chicken [ __ ] on his hands it
was a little character moment there
wasn't anything to it
but then i just thought it would be
really cool if we paid it off in the end
where lorraine
is there you know she kind of goes back
to casters and she's
she's talking with him and she touches
his hand and maybe it's by
maybe she has a gut feeling or something
but by touching her hand
his hand it's a flash of the past and
she you know connects to
you know his child and you know his
story and we
we see it play out there and um i think
that that was
you know one of those very specific
moment and i just thought oh my god it
would be great because on a second
viewing you go back and it's like it
wasn't chicken [ __ ]
he was aware she was a psychic and
dodging the hand grabbing
um but you know that was one of those
moments where you know i think
i think it was uh dlj david leslie
johnson our writer you know brought up
the point he was like
once you add hand touching to a psychic
ability i mean that goes in the
that goes in the the arsenal you know
you can't really walk that back you
she'll just touch any hand of any
suspect and then it's over
um so so yeah that was one of those
moments where we kind of we pulled back
what was it like approaching a conjuring
film
where the big bad isn't necessarily your
quintessential
demon like it's all it's more human
wielding that kind of power because
that's that is another way like we were
discussing before with this movie
getting out and about
that this deviates big time from the
other film so was there any concern that
i don't know that reveal would be a
letdown or not as cool as having the big
exorcism scene which is what you have at
the beginning of the movie and it's
still well done there
um yeah i guess well if you want a big
exorcism at the end of this movie you
gotta just watch it in reverse you gotta
like pull a tenant
and just like put it on rewind um
i think that it uh
you know hey if a franchise is gonna
evolve you gotta start kicking the tires
on these things and
it was something that i thought was the
coolest thing
possible um you know and you know i was
talking to you guys about you know
testing and the demon that we lost
you know in a way i thought okay this is
gonna be the next iconic demon and you
know it was awesome like the thrill of
like you know
making that and making that demon with
james and being like oh my god
this is the next nun i cannot wait
and then the movie just it couldn't fit
it it didn't really
it didn't really make sense for the
movie and honestly i think everybody
deserves like
a pat on the back for for letting it go
because i think it just shows that
you know everybody's is wants it to
evolve and we don't want to just keep on
repeating the same things
you know and ultimately i think it makes
for a more interesting story and a more
human story you know and
even the one of the things
that you know we went back and um
was part of uh additional photography
was
the um we expanded the relationship with
with kastner there was always a threat
of it
but part of it was was we love john
noble and john noble was just
tearing up the screen and it was like oh
my god we just need to do
like the john noble spin-off or we could
like just watch like 20 more minutes of
him just reading
you know out of the bible um
so we wanted more of him but you know we
started just expanding you know his
story and telling you know that
relationship and
ultimately what it what i really like
about that
and is it starts to look
at the conjuring movies from a different
perspective
you know this the movie is about you
know you have all these mirrors you have
you know arnie and debbie mir um near
the warrens you know it's kind of like a
you know
mirror image of them as a couple you
have um
you have our occultist you know she
married she mirrors uh
lorraine you know she's like the bizarro
evil version of her
and then also with kastner in kastner's
artifact room or castro's library
it's a mirror of the warrens themselves
and
i think that that idea i thought was
awesome and it it starts to let us look
at the warrens in a different
perspective and i think it's the type of
thing that you can
you know you know up to this point you
know the warrens are awesome and the
warrens always win
and you know everything always works out
great and there's no victims
in a conjuring movie and then we have
this story
where there's a real murder here and
there's a real victim
and what did the true warrens do they
stuck to their beliefs
and they came to the defense of the most
unlikely person
not of the victim they came to the
defense of the murder and you know
there's
you know the there's a lot of things
that you know
a lot of people love the warrens i love
the warrens i love their story
but there's there's some things that the
warrens did that i think we can question
and we can you know wonder about you
know
i i you know they were controversial
characters and this was their most
controversial case
and they believed in what they believed
and they they went to court
to prove it and they they stood behind
arnie and i think that that is
you know that's that's a controversial
idea i think it's also a testament to
their own faith in what they're doing
but i think that there was something
very cool about the idea of it that
you know we could explore the dark side
of it we could explore this kind of
you know conjuring movie where things
don't work out all right and things
do go horribly wrong and in a way
with kastner we we could talk about like
the darker side of the warrens and the
darker side of
what they do and you know these movies
are always about
kids getting into the artifact room it's
like kids
opening that dart like playing with that
evil toy playing with the like the
haunted thing unlocking evil and then
thank god the warrens come in and they
save the day you know they
they take the evil toy away they put in
the artifact room ever
no victims everyone's everyone's fine
this is one of the the moments where you
know
they they fail and i think what was so
cool with castner is that's a
we could tell kastner's story and his
obsession and his artifact room
and his own child who got into the
artifact room
and never came out so
yeah i mean i so rewind let me actually
try and tie that back into your story
answer your question
um which was i don't even remember at
this point i've gone so far
down the rabbit hole i think you're
talking about like the obligation or the
no
not having the the demon like the
expectation
of the executive
you know ultimately
you know so many people ask me what's
the cool iconic monster in this
what is it you know what you know and in
a way it's like
i think we also just had to kick the
tires it's like are we just making
you know uh uh
you know conjuring toys or like branded
spin-offs or are we trying to tell human
stories that really explore these
you know who these characters are and i
think
and i'm not saying that we come came out
the movie in the very beginning with
like with that kind of absolute clarity
because we were trying to
come up with our new awesome demon
um but i do think that there was
something really powerful about
the idea of trying to tell the most
human warren story and tell it both with
the the warrens
and then also with you know with the
their other characters you could still
tell a human story and a story that
warrants things like
like conjuring funko pops i would still
buy them
whether there's demon in this one or not
are you saying there's not going gonna
be a uh castner funko pop i mean
he is so the iconic one coupon
if they made it and he was included i
would need the whole set
i think people would would buy an ed
warren with a cane funko
yeah right i second that
all right do it do you have anything
else we only have a couple minutes haley
so do we want to do our last two or
another spoiler i i was going to pose
that to you i'm happy to move
on to last night all right all right
let's move on and i'll give you the
honor
haley we always ask our guests the same
last two questions
haley do you want to pick one first
you know what i'm going to pick i yeah
probably
do you have any pets any pets
yes tell us about your pets if you have
them uh you know i had a cat that passed
away
during la uranus so yeah i'm sorry
he's with me in spirit i have two little
kids
who are kind of like animals
i feel like as uh as animal lovers we
often we often forget that like some
people have have human pets children
it's like it's like every time my sister
talks about my niece i'm always like
yeah well dewey my cat did this
yesterday
yeah it's uh well they can go to the
bathroom in the toilet eventually so
there's that a plus but i've seen cats
that can do
the same so i don't know i'd be very
impressed if dewey ever did that's not
happening
our other last question is always what
is
some piece of genre storytelling that
you've experienced recently that you
would recommend to our viewers it could
be something new
something old a movie a show a comic you
name it
possessor i thought that was awesome
very very good choice we're big
possessor fans here
yeah great go and see it guys after
you've seen
the contrary and the devil made me do it
in theaters and then also
uh started a subscription for hbo max
then go
see possess possessor
off of your gift for self-promotion and
say after you do all those things
then go listen to our witching hour
interview with brandon cronenberg
ah i gotta hear that it was a good
conversation
but also if anyone's still here that
hasn't seen the movie what's what's
wrong with you but i'll just take this
opportunity to plug it again
and let you know that it's available in
theaters and on hbo max and if you have
anyone in your life
who has not seen it tell them to go see
it and just continue
spreading the love michael thank you so
much for joining us for the witching
hour we appreciate your time and
all your stories i love hearing about
this congratulations
and thank you again i was about to not
do our outro
he's like about to do like a very
traditional wrap it up and move on
this is it it's over you have officially
survived
the witching hour
you